Rous drops it off for KERO just on to the ice
and curve foot leftt it for maell and broken up
nicely by the Sharks and mle cranin races the
other way with duclair drops for gry feeds the
slot and the shot goes wide play goal in the last
game I think that keeps him in the lineup just
competing jumps up in the play and here you can
see the transition for the San Jose Sharks really
quick up ice duclair back to granin gr was looking
all the way across to eckan but then sees McDonald
Kelly feeds it back to dery left point and now
schaltz feeds it back along to Stater therey a
one timer kicked out by Blackwood and you know the
23-year-old and 22-year- old they just didn't have
a great night so he split them up here against
Arizona and you can see it's made a difference
gunan flips it in and on a backand tried to Center
for the crease a whistle stops play with the net
off its Moorings and the Sharks picking that
one out of the air off the rush and there was
a change here as cunan just uses his speed into
the neutral zone it's just chipped to the middle
of the ice and it's a bouncing Puck that Fela
just gets with his left pad he's had a ton of
traffic from his own teammates from some San Jose
Sharks and there you can see that's a beautiful
save as cunan and Le Bank could really created
a two on0 there moer does a nice job getting a
little he Pride it free from Eckland and lifted
to seven brought down by Ferraro couldn't get it
past dery now Ekman slides it for Zena and Vela
makes the stop Anon the rebound on Eckland as
well so David Quinn gets a really good ship
from the cunon line and then he goes right
back to the hurdle line that's arguably been
his best offensive line early in this hockey
game as Zena gets a chance e but he is heated
up for Arizona hurdle kept it in eckan gloves
it down feeds it back for AA trying to trigger
and he can and now hurdle along the wall with 15
seconds beads it across Ferraro centers for milk
of the stop on Zaden yeah Zena and eckan were in
front of the net and both had an opportunity a
nice little job on the four check by toas hurtle
using his big body and look at the pass across
to Ferraro but look at the options Ferraro had
eckan and just come on to the ice and
now duclair races back for the sharks
Anthony duclair pulls up and a good stick by
Keller kessle ring carries out connects through
set ice with Clayton Keller Keller dancing in
beating kenle ring he scores gorgeous from Keller
to Kastle ring and the coyotes strike first on the
road and as we watch the coyotes come
through the neutral zone with speed and
just a nice job by kessle ring to time it
coming down the middle of the ice getting
his stick free and Keller spots him
and he goes Far Side over the glove
on Blackwood but the way that Keller caught
this Puck as he was entering the Zone was
unbelievable Dumba chips it ahead kerfoot
stayed onside drops schaltz tried to work
it back to the line for Moser it's a collision
duclair's Off to the Races duclair scores TI
W and a ton of credit here great defensive
Zone Play Just pushes the puck to space in
the neutral zone you're going to see that coyot
Collide and that allows jair peaches Off to the
Races and you think about two games ago he was
a healthy scratch he had a little bit of energy
against the LA Kings well tonight he had some
energy I mean we've seen this a couple of times
through throughout the game his speed through the
neutral zone just phenomenal and what a finish a
nice little fake cunning gets it back up ice
with Bailey here's biley darting in over the
line back toward the slot and picked off pass
a little bit of high to hoto Keller is in here
is Keller and Blackwood trying to keep it out
he scores slipped it right through the wickets
Clayton Keller puts the coyotes back in front
his last four games played Clayton Keller has
had but you see the turnover by the Sharks
they're trying to get a chance but they get
flat on the attack and it goes right up ice and
the San Jose Sharks defenseman get a little too
far apart and look at this hits the post it
actually goes back off Blackwood and into the
net he got help from his post on the initial shot
and you'll see it just trickles through stick goes
soaring away from buad McDonald shot was Tipp by
Bailey McDonald kept it alive flicked it Forward
big collision with Cur foot at the wall McDonald
p leank leank got it and a save for Mila last two
games keeps the puck in with a good physical
presence just a nice little pass to open ice
and look at that he's only taken six shifts in
this game remember he had that hit laid on him
by Matt Dumba at Center Ice we have not seen Smith
recently here schals fed it back across and they
score now let's see what happens it was Cur foot
parked in front on Blackwood and CER foot on the
receiving end from schaltz five hole when he
goes down there's a feeling that maybe he lifts
his stick and you can see it there they fake the
shot and does it hit kerfoot that might just go
off to San Jose shark's defenseman and it might
be the skate of kerfoot the right skate and for
the coyotes neither is Jack McBain out on the
bench areas egland went spinning and centering
carams into the corner hurdle goes down by the
net Ferraro's on it pinching in working it out in
front they scor sadena poked it in past the left
pad of Vela and oh did the Sharks need that it's a
one goal game had some bite to it throughout this
game they've been in on the four check they've
created the majority of the San Jose Shark chances
and they finally get Warden just really good job
down low with Ferraro jumping up into the play
as the Sharks defenseman and theena just really
pokes this forward doesn't even get a shot off
just pokes it towards the net as it's missed
by moer busted stick for the Sharks dery fanned
on it weaving past the stickless Bailey and then
glove out at Center by Krauss reentry melli off
to the wing Krauss on net Blackwood makes another
stop loose for buad couldn't trigger now he fires
and it's off the iron he's had about four or five
chances after that St could turn over and this
is a last melli spins back at the line for dery
moved along Schmaltz in the bumper spot dery for
melli they play catch dery feeds it in for Keller
Keller back to dery walking along the line Keller
with space Keller to the line and SCH scores on
the power play it's Scholtz and the lead is
two again again for the coyotes Tic Tac Toe
pass until he actually makes the play just watch
the little stick handle it's a subtle little play
right here stick handle stick handle down low
you have no idea as a goaler if he's going to
shoot or not and he gets the Quick Pass to kerfoot
moves the defender and that allows smz to be wide
open pass e for leank try to slip it out past
bu's Dad but he collects and finds melli theas
melli P it across for Krauss high slot scores
losson kuss from out High makes it a five spot
for Arizona up the ice for the coyotes it was a
a four on three for just way too long look at the
San Jose Sharks two players coming back just not
enough effort and yeah really did some increase
and really worked on his Fitness get a little
stronger and one timer from burrow fand on Puck
loose Hurd trying to swat that home with zadina
Vela sprawled out eckan behind and dery caral it
Arizona woke up in a big way with its offense in
the second and on the road the coyotes will make
it a four game winning streak in playoff position
headed toward Christmas Arizona wins again